i thought it was interesting gaza came  out with pressure right away from the  first possession usually they wait a  little bit they like that one two two  three quarter court but they came with  it right away  homegrown with the flush went down with  an injury here in the first half and has  not returned and they're up to  timmy to holmgren  doctors are still evaluating he will be  back on the bench at some point it is a  knee injury they are fearing the worst  but they cannot  until they get the full evaluation but  he is definitely out  [Applause]  robert's trying to slice through the  lane tough pass scott is rejected can  protect the basket a great pass and he  comes from the weak side  i'd like to see how far he can get on  one dribble  to the basket you might see it here  [Applause]